welcome back to a special cbs this
morning we are live in washington dc
with unprecedented security
and pandemic restrictions today's
inauguration you already know this will
look so different from anything that
we've ever seen in the past
that includes a traditional parade down
pennsylvania avenue
national correspondent jerica duncan
joins us from the parade route which
means eureka
you're in washington too i'm so glad
you're here we're all glad to be here
good morning good to see you too good
morning what can we expect today
in just a few short hours you can expect
to see that new president
and the new first lady walking down
pennsylvania avenue
it'll be a very short parade before it
turns virtual
but one highlight that we were able to
witness yesterday was a sneak peek of
one of the bands that will be
escorting the new president and vice
president kamala harris
that's the howard drum line a nod to
vice president-elect kamala harris's
alma mater
the group had been rehearsing virtually
all this time last night's practice
was the first time they'd seen each
other in about nine
months junior carla bonnick says she
plays the symbols in the drum line
she said she's so proud to represent a
part of vice president-elect harris's
historic win i saw this school
as a place where black excellence is and
this election
and kamala harris winning the election
just goes to show what can come from
this university
what are your hopes for now this will no
doubt be a secure
perimeter again that virtual parade will
get underway after the short one here
gail i'll take it rica thank you very
much good to see you